[Música]
escenas como estas se han vuelto cada
vez más comunes en Estados Unidos y es
algo con lo que el gobierno quiere
terminar el presidente Joe biden anunció
una nueva orden ejecutiva al respecto
para aumentar la comprobación de
antecedentes antes de vender armas
[Aplausos]
es de sentido común comprobar si alguien
es un delincuente un maltratador
doméstico etcétera antes de que compre
un arma y estoy cada vez más decidido a
prohibir las armas de asalto y los
cargadores de alta capacidad
Y es que Estados Unidos está viviendo
una oleada de tiroteos contra civiles
uno de los más recientes El de Monterrey
parque en California un hombre entró a
un salón de baile y mató a disparos a 11
personas
es agresor tenía problemas mentales y
debería haber sido señalado por la ley
como bandera roja para venderle armas
así Alguien podría haber ido y haberle
quitado las armas
en el país se registran más de 40.000
muertes por arma de fuego al año sucesos
que han despertado cada vez más las
voces de alarma sobre la necesidad de un
mayor control en su uso
una de las tragedias que más concienció
al respecto fue la de ubalde Texas en la
que un hombre compró un rifle Solo un
día después de cumplir 18 años con el
que entró a una escuela primaria y mató
a 19 alumnos y dos profesores un mes
después salió adelante una ley
bipartidista sobre el control de armas
que genera roces entre los republicanos
y los demócratas en el congreso no
obstante vaiden está decidido a seguir
con sus políticas sobre las armas y
hacer de ellas una bandera de Cara a las
elecciones de 2024